des prix cassés un geste bien connu une
forte affluence au niveau des caisses
les soldes d'hiver ont officiellement
débuté ce mercredi 10 janvier dans cette
boutique de plaisir une dizaine de
clients n'ont pas hésité à se lever très
tôt pour trouver la perle rare ah parce
que tout simplement sa part très vite et
que jusqu'à moins 50 moins 60 cas dans
les bonnes tailles sa part le premier
jour où le premier week-end sur un coup
de chance on peut trouver les choses
mais c'est plus compliqué c'est mieux on
va dire parce que malheureusement défend
en attendant la première démarque on a
pu les tailles c'est bien de devenir le
premier jour
cette année les boutiques ont décidé de
baisser les prix dès le jour j pour
concurrencer les plateformes internet
les clients peuvent acheter des produits
au tarif de la deuxième démarque dès la
première semaine allez on en profite
mais da moins 10% supplémentaires des
deux articles achetés jusqu'à 14h faut
en profiter c'est maintenant on peut
passer d'un pull à 35 euros 99 un
chemisier à 25 euros 99 1 les vraiment
les prix de nos jours ont plus augmenté
comparé à bon donc du coup les seuls
sont vraiment plus intéressante
aujourd'hui affluence des grands jours
également dans les centres commerciaux
de montigny le bretonneux dans ce
magasin spécialisé dans les collants
l'affluence et 40% plus élevé que sur un
jour classiques bas les gens attendez un
peu que ça allait salle d'un malgré les
ventes privées qui avait avant là ça les
arrange bien aussi de voir que c'est
carrément à 50 certains n'ont pas hésité
à empiéter sur la pause déjeuner pour
faire chauffer la carte bleue
des colons je suis parce que j'en avais
besoin mais du coup comme j'en ai vu à
-50% bas je les ai pris je n'aurais pas
pris s'il aurait été pris en compte
[Musique]
cette cliente repartira finalement avec
20 euros de collants dans son panier en
moyenne un français devraient dépenser
200 euros les soldes se termineront dans
six semaines le 20 février prochain